[MUSIC PLAYING]
TIMOTHY JORDAN: So here
we are on Main Street.
It's pretty much the
main thoroughfare
at Google I/O 2017.
I figured let's take a stroll
and see what's going on,
want to come with me?
OK.
Hi, everybody.
Enjoying the festival?
OK.
Good.
So apparently, this is
an AR, augmented reality,
for those paying attention.
Well, I haven't figured out
how to do it just yet, though.
Maybe it's over this way.
Just one of the many
things you could do here
in between the sessions.
I believe this is
dancing, right?
So let's go over here.
So one of the coolest
things that I found here
on Main Street is
the opportunity
to send a postcard
out to anybody.
I'm choosing to send
it to future Timothy.
Shall we write me a few notes?
OK.
Hi.
I'm going to join you all
here and write a postcard.
Well, who did you write to?
SPEAKER 1: I'm writing back
home to Georgia, the country,
quite far, so let's see how
long it takes to get there.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: We'll find out.
I'm sending mine
to future Timothy.
SPEAKER 1: Wow, can I do that?
But not future Timothy,
but future Nina.
Can I send it to myself?
TIMOTHY JORDAN: Yes,
let's both do it here.
I'm just going to
write mine over here
SPEAKER 1: But I
don't know where
I will be living at the time?
TIMOTHY JORDAN: What was that?
SPEAKER 1: I don't know were
you living at that time.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: Well, if you
send the postcard now, future
you is any time after now.
So you're good.
SPEAKER 1: OK. so the
address is future.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: Yes.
Let's see, you had a great
time at I/O, smiley face.
Are you still writing
the address there?
SPEAKER 1: Yes.
It's pretty long.
I'll get there.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: Are all the
addresses in Georgia long?
SPEAKER 1: No, not really, OK.
So, but you had the yours
written, so that was cheating.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: Yes.
SPEAKER 1: OK.
OK.
Hey.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: It's OK.
We'll wait.
SPEAKER 1: I have
you are doing well.
Take care.
I'm so nice to myself.
Take care, and good
luck with your startup.
I have a start up.
OK.
Great, so--
TIMOTHY JORDAN: I think
we've got to mail them.
SPEAKER 1: All right.
There was more,
more of these guys.
Next time?
TIMOTHY JORDAN: OK.
SPEAKER 1: OK.
Here it goes.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: Bye.
SPEAKER 1: Thank you.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: See you.
SPEAKER 1: See
you in the future.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: OK.
All right.
Let's check out what
this wall is all about.
SPEAKER 2: How's it going?
TIMOTHY JORDAN: It's going well.
How are you?
SPEAKER 2: I'm great, thanks.
I'm having a great time here.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: It's
a developer festival.
How could you not
have a good time?
SPEAKER 2: I have
no idea honestly.
It's beautiful out.
It's an awesome time.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: So tell me
what's going on with this wall.
It's more than
just a wall, right?
SPEAKER 2: It is more
than just the wall.
So this is actually
going to be an AR mural.
So as you can see there's
a lot of little icons
and things on the screen.
If I actually put
up my tablet here,
you can see that
there's actually
going be floating overlays.
So this AR, is being generated,
because of these triggers
within the actual mural itself.
So there's a couple of different
icons and different animations
here.
So here you can see there's
going to be the Google I/O
icon spinning.
And so what we've
been doing today,
is just taking little short,
five second GIFs for people,
and then, being
able to send them
to them so they have that
kind of a memento of today.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: Awesome.
I love it.
SPEAKER 2: Do you
want to do one?
TIMOTHY JORDAN: I do, but can
you send me a gift, not a GIF?
SPEAKER 2: I don't
know about that.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: Whatever.
SPEAKER 2: OK.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
There you go.
It's going to generate
a little preview.
So there you are jumping
around in the background.
What do you think?
TIMOTHY JORDAN:
That's very cool.
It's got the heel
click and everything.
SPEAKER 2: Exactly.
Awesome.
TIMOTHY JORDAN:
Thank you so much.
SPEAKER 2: You're very welcome.
Of course.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: All right.
Let's go somewhere else.
[MUSIC PLAYING]